اجواء تعكس حجم الدمار والمجازر التي
يمارسها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه
هذه الساحه عاده ما كانت مكتظه بال
المحتفلين
باللون الاحمر
ب المصطفين بال الناس الان هي شبه فارغه
لا يوجد هنا الا العدد الاكبر هم من وسائل
الاعلام العالميه والاحتفالات هنا تحول
الى مظاهر وطنيه نسمع في الخلفيه اغاني
تتحدث عن شهداء غزه الان تم رفع علم
فلسطين هو يعني كما نرى على امتداد ساحه
كنيسه المهد التي رفعها اطفال من مخيمات
بيت لحم وايضا عدد من النشطاء الفلسطينيين
ايضا لاول مره في تاريخ الشعب الفلسطين من
الن لا يجد شجره عيد الميلاد لا يوجد هذه
الشجره التي هي تمثل اعياد الميلاد بدلا
منها نرى هذا العمل الفني الذي يربط بين
التاريخ بين الحاضر
وبين رساله الميلاد هذا عمل فني قام به
فنان فلسطيني استغرق العمل فيه ثلاثه
اسابيع كما نرى احراج احجار مدمره تمثل
الدمار في غزه العائله المقدسه عباره
عن كفن للسيد المسيح عليه السلام كاول
شهيد
فلسطيني المجوس يحمل ايضا كفنه بمعنى ان
اهل غزه يحملون
اكفانهم هذا الحديد الاسود باللون السكني
تحديدا وليس الاسود يمثل خارطه فلسطين
وايضا يمثل خارطه قطاع غزه ان فلسطين
واحده ايضا نجمه الميلاد التي هي اهم شعار
لدى المسيحيين هي عباره عن
صاروخ اسرائيلي يمثل صاروخ اسرائيلي
اسقط في داخل القطاع ليقتل هذا الكم
الهائل من الاطفال والشهداء اكثر من 20 ال
فلسطيني استشهدوا في قطاع غزه اليوم من
بيت لحم الرساله ترسل الى العالم الذي
بالطبع كل انظار العالم تتجه الغربي
تحديدا تتجه عاده الى هنا الى بيت لحم
اليوم ستكون الرساله الى العالم الغربي
اوقفوا الحرب على غزه اوقفوا العدوان
الاساس ان العالم الغربي وهذا ما سيتم
التركيز عليه بعد قليل هو اتهامات حركه
حماس بان السبب بكل ما حدث بان الاحتلال
هو السبب بكل ما حدث وهذا هو الشعار
الرئيسي الشعب الفلسطيني يعيش منذ النكبه
تحت الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ليزالجيريان